a mother at the center of a
discrimination lawsuit against red rock
country club is asking for help now
while her case moves forward brian
and it's a story denise 80s now has been
following closely since back in 2019 the
i-team's vanessa murphy now has more
carmel mary hill filed a discrimination
complaint against red rock country club
in 2016.
today she says her biracial daughters
jessie and bella
still ask if they're to blame i'm like
no i said that was a decision of someone
that
didn't do the right thing that's not
your fault hill says she brought her
daughters to a daycare center at the
club while working there as a tennis
instructor
and after a long time white country club
member was overheard stating
whose black kids are these and
complained to management
hill was fired she says after she filed
a complaint with the nevada equal rights
commission
she was banned from the property too it
was never about the money for me it was
about
making them accountable for their
actions and
them to make better practices at red
rock country club
the equal rights commission issued a
probable cause finding of discrimination
and retaliation
hill filed a federal lawsuit she says
her attorney hasn't charged fees at this
point
but she started this gofundme account as
the case is not resolved
i started a gofundme to help with
the cost of doing this and i also
wanted to help others they go through
the same thing and need advice
or maybe need some help financially to
uh hire a lawyer hill says she is still
banned from red rock country club's
property which affects her daughters
since they play tennis tournaments we
reached out to attorneys for the country
club and did not receive a response in
time for this report
vanessa murphy 8 news now